hi hey supposed to be a Milwaukee
killing your husband so why are you here
murder is wrong Sharon sure if it man
nobody's perfect was I cheating on you
maybe I know those things are happening
do I just um I just like stuck ball
McGee you're just a work in progress
babe sure how'd you do that a lot of
condoms
wow you look great excuse me waiter I
cut I'm on a date and I like this girl
can't we do this tomorrow hey did you
have to finish a book on tape no sorry
had to kill somebody in the parking lot
yeah into it why would anybody kill our
guy and public like that go blow his
face off he seems like a sexy Rain Man
or something thank you you are FBI when
you have it Assad a new target he's
normally one of the world's most
notorious professional killers he quit
no he developed a moral code he said
he'd killed a guy in the parking lot I
thought he was joking people still try
to hire him but now he kills him he
kills the people who hired him yeah my
dad just unconscious this whole reverse
hitman thing is like it's weird I know
you're like the greatest and then you
kill he Bolin
this guy's a supersonic psycho killer I
just shoot him in the face some crack
hasn't buckling with better guns gonna
get out of here it's bad you look
handsome Thanks yeah i'm in love with
them is not stupid yeah hard yes
is really don't know his name who mr.
rice yeah mr. right bang bang okay we
are feeling a hundred Knights hidden
Afghans in rotational assignee hundreds
zips just eats